les simone d'orléans affrontent les
cannibales de grenoble elle mène au
score
ça chauffe pour les orléanaises c'est
une équipe forte en fast au cas
effectivement bon de nous tous c'est
toujours éprouvant mais ça
façon assez cynique ans
au roller derby il n'y a pas de balle
les attaquantes marque des points quand
elles arrivent à dépasser l'équipe
adverse c'est un sport qui allie vitesse
et combat où on joue des épaules des
fesses et les hanches
alors pour faire du roller derby il faut
des quads des rollers à l'ancienne les
protège genoux les protège coudes les
protège poignets le protège dents et le
casque au roller derby on y vient pour
le sport mais aussi pour l'ambiance show
à l'américaine
l'action il ya une bonne ambiance la
musique qui nous plaît on aime bien
suspens
bonne ambiance et une sono de mentalité
ce jeu venus d'amérique du nord est
arrivé en 2007 en france
il réunit plus de 4000 adeptes dans
l'hexagone ce qui m'a attiré c'est le
dépassement de soi l'esprit d'équipé et
le vêtement sa copine hadj le jeu il est
fait par les joueuses pour les joueurs
il a été créé par des femmes
qu'on est capable
donner d'être portée des puissantes
ensemble et c'est ça qui me plaît
vraiment dans ce sport c'est
le fait de donner le meilleur de
soi-même et de jouer pour nous
vraiment ça
très important et c'est ensemble que les
équipes construisent leur stratégie de
jeu de la tactique que les orléanais
pourront apprécier en janvier 2018 lors
des matches de championnat de france qui
se dérouleront dans la métropole
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]